maintenue est un peu atypique ce soir
c'est la tenue que j'ai enfin une partie
en tout cas de l'équipement que j'ai
utilisée en antarctique
comme vous pouvez le voir sur cette
photo pour skier notamment par moins 50
degrés alors je vous le concède c'est
pas la tenue la plus sexy mais lorsque
la température chute à moins 50 degrés
et que le vent souffle à 80 km/heure et
s'engouffre par tout autour du visage
c'est très utile pour éviter les risques
de jets dur dans quelques minutes vous
en saurez beaucoup plus sur cette
incroyable expédition et aventure que
j'ai vécu à travers le continent
antarctique
comme il fait quand même un peu
meilleure dans cette salle qu'en
antarctique je me dévêtir un peu pour
vous raconter cette expédition
cette aventure elle commence en réalité
en france sur les bancs de l'école et
peut-être même un peu un peu avant
vous savez on est tous aventuriers je
veux dire à la naissance dès la
naissance
nous sommes tous des aventuriers
l'enfance être un enfant c'est peut-être
un aventurier et probablement même un
aventurier de l'extrême
lorsque l'on apprend à marcher on tombe
on se relève on se fait mal on tombe à
nouveau mais on recommence à chaque fois
et c'est en quelque sorte une aventure
de l'extrême
quand on apprend à parler à écrire quand
on découvre le monde qui nous entoure
c'est aussi une aventure l'enfance c'est
au fond le moment de notre vie où l'on
prend le plus de risques
où on n'a peur de rien où l'on croit
dans nos rêves même les plus fous et
c'est aussi le moment de notre vie de
notre vie à tous où l'on à une courbe de
croissance qui est la plus importante la
plus exponentielle et à un moment de
notre vie lorsqu'on a grandi
physiquement leur a grandi
intellectuellement souvent après avoir
quitté notamment les bancs de l'école
on a tendance à agrandir un peu moins on
se lance dans une activité
professionnelle qui peut être une très
belle aventure aussi en soi mais trop
souvent on a tendance à rechercher une
zone de confort sans prise de risque
sans changement on renonce à nos rêves
d'enfants comme on pourrait se laisser
endormir par le froid et à partir de ce
moment là souvent on arrête de grandir
tout simplement et arrêté de grandir
c'est déjà un peu commencé à mourir avec
mon épouse stéphanie que j'ai rencontrés
sur les bancs de l'école à un moment où
on était plus complètement enfants mais
pas non plus complètement adultes on a
grandi ensemble et puis on a aussi
quitté les bancs de l'école
on a commencé notre activité
professionnelle très épanouissante
en tant qu'avocat on a exercé ainsi
pendant une dizaine d'années
passionnant et puis en même temps tous
les matins le costume la chemise la
cravate
la routine qui s'installe en quelque
sorte et puis peu à peu nos rêves
d'enfants c'est face et on commence à
les oublier
avec stéphanie notre rêve c'était de
découvrir le monde
lorsque nous étions plus jeunes nous
n'avons pas eu l'occasion de voyager
beaucoup de quitter les frontières de
notre pays mais nous avons toujours eu
cette volonté d'aller découvrir le monde
et en particulier les régions polaires
nous avons lu tous les récits
d'expéditions polaires que ce soit en
arctique et en antarctique
et puis un jour un matin est venue cette
idée folle mais alors vraiment folle
l'idée de traverser l'antarctique en ski
alors comment savoir qu'une idée est
vraiment fort il ya quelques critères
assez simple la première c'est lorsque
personne d'autres que vous ne crois que
cette idée est possible et réalisable
c'est un bon indice est avec stéphanie
lorsque l'on a eu cette idée qu'on a
commencé à la partager autour de nous y
compris auprès de nos proches
les personnes qui ont cru dans notre
capacité à aller au bout de ce rêve de
cet objectif se compter sur les doigts
d'une main
il y a eu ensuite beaucoup d'autres
indices qui nous ont démontré que cette
idée était vraiment folle
par exemple pour n'en citer qu'un
lorsqu'un de nos partenaires potentiels
s'est retiré de la vente sûrs elle nous
a dit finalement je ne vous passerez pas
à ces équipements que que je vous avais
plus ou moins promis parce que j'ai trop
peur que vous irez astier et cela
pourrait être préjudiciable pour mon
image
c'était aussi un bon indice mais comme
on n'est pas complètement vous ni mon
épouse et moi-même nous nous sommes
préparés autant que possible nous savons
qu'en antarctique chaque détail compte
chaque détail est important lorsque la
température chute à moins 50 degrés nous
avons notamment
effectuer des séances d'entraînement
dans des entrepôts frigorifiques le
samedi matin à 4h ou 5h du matin nous
sommes allés courir dans ces entrepôts
frigorifiques à moins 25 degrés pendant
cinq ou six heures pour tester des
équipements et avec l' avantage de le
vivre en couple parce que je vous
concède bien volontiers le faire seul
mort est probablement coûté mon mariage
nous sommes aussi aller tracter des
roues sur la plage sur le sable pendant
des heures et des heures des dizaines de
kilomètres pour ressentir ce que pouvait
être l'effort de tracter un traîneau de
60 70 kg sur la glace nous sommes aussi
allés réaliser des tests en altitude
les tests d'effort pour voir comment
notre organisme allait réagir
et puis il ya eu toute la préparation
logistique et financière pour réaliser
cette expédition
nous savons aussi parce que nous avons
lu tous ces récits d'expédition et au
moment où nous les avons refermé pour
vivre nous mêmes cette incroyable
expérience et vivre pleinement notre vie
nous savions aussi que parmi les
quelques aventuriers qui se sont rendus
en antarctique qui ont exploré ce
continent depuis le début du 20e siècle
tous ne sont pas revenus et c'est
probablement la raison aussi pour
laquelle cette aventure cette expédition
était était un peu folle nous y voilà
donc le 14 novembre 2014
un petit avion un bimoteur nous dépose
sur la côte de l'antarctique et ils
redécolle et il nous laisse face à cette
immensité d'un continent grands comme 20
fois la france d'un désert de glace un
désert extrêmes le le plus élevé de la
planète
le pôle sud culmine à 3000 m le plus
froid avec une température moyenne de
-53 degrés et le plus sexy plus sec que
le sahara nous y voilà donc sur le point
de réaliser ce rêve de le débuter en
tout cas
avec à ce moment-là précis de cette
expédition le sentiment d'avoir déjà
accompli quelque chose de fort le simple
fait d'être sur ce continent et de deux
touchés ce rêve de nos doigts et déjà
fort et on sent à ce moment-là tout
tous ces regards qui nous observent
virtuellement de toutes les personnes
qui finalement quand même ont cru que ce
projet était réalisable
tous ces collégiens ces lycéens qui ont
décidé de nous suivre dans l'aventuré
les partenaires qui ont accepté de nous
soutenir également on les ressent tout
autour de nous et on se dit que
maintenant il faut vraiment tout donné
pour aller au bout de cette aventure
parce qu'on ne peut pas décevoir leur
confiance et puis on ne peut pas
s'empêcher de penser aussi à tout ce qui
peut être et n'y ont pas cru
avec cette volonté que l'on a de leur
montrer que c'est possible d'atteindre
un objectif lorsque l'on y croit nous
partons donc sans trop nous attarder
parce que nous sommes donc le 14
novembre 2014 et nous savons que nous
n'avons uniquement que 74 jours pour
réaliser cette traversée pourquoi parce
que le 28 janvier 2015
le dernier avion en partance de
l'antarctique à destination de punta
arenas au chili s'envolera il laissera
derrière lui l'hiver austral
enveloppez l'antarctique d'une nuit
polaire de six mois et nous savons que
nous devons être à bord de cet avion
si nous voulons revenir jusqu'en france
nous démarrons donc cette longue
traversée progressivement très
progressivement pour que le corps
s'adapte à l'effort on skie huit heures
par jour
on s'arrête toutes les heures pour faire
une pause de dix minutes pouvoir se
ravitailler un peu récupérer de l'eau
dans nos terme aux pourboires et puis
l'on repart l'un derrière l'autre avec
la boussole que l'on adapte en fonction
de l'indication que donne le gps et l'on
progresse comme ça le jour après jour
arrive le 7e jour de l'expédition et à
ce moment là la société de logistique
qui nous suit et que nous contactons
tous les jours pour reporter notre
notre position gps notamment par mesure
de sécurité qui nous donne aussi des
indications sur la météo 7ce backup
logistique nous dit tout simplement qu'à
ce rythme là nous n'avons aucune chance
de traverser l'antarctique et que les
rations alimentaires que nous avons
prises seront insuffisantes pour aller
au bout avec stéphanie on s'accroche
parce que l'on sait pour avoir couru des
très longues distances en course à pied
entre l on sait que la course ça ne
commence qu'à mes distances
on conserve notre rythme on conserve
cette mise en route et on continue à
avancer
la glace est très très abrasives
l'antarctique et commun un océan de
glace avec des vagues qui sont
passionnés par le vent c'est très
surprenant c'est très beau une beauté
intrigante mais qui en même temps nous
ralentit de plus en plus arrive le
quatorzième jour de l'expédition le
brouillard nous enveloppe depuis
quelques jours un brouillard très
oppressant brouillard blanc la ligne
d'horizon a disparu depuis longtemps en
avance dès vingtaine de kilomètres par
jour en ayant l'impression de faire du
surplace et alors que l'horizon commence
à réapparaître légèrement ces familles
qui est devant moi s'arrête brusquement
et m'a dit que nous sommes juste devant
une immense crevasses cet immense
crevasses nous aurions dû la contourner
mais nous avons fait une erreur de
cheminement et contacts pris auprès de
la société de logistique sur notre notre
back up nous confirme que nous devons la
contourner aller trop longs ou trop
large trop risqué nous faisons donc un
détour de 10 km et nous allons poser
notre campement 14 kilomètres plus loin
et nous avons encore pris un peu plus de
retard mais nous nous accrochons et nous
continuons à avancer coûte que coûte
nous prenons le temps aussi de prendre
des images les photographies des vidéos
parce que notre objectif principal n'est
peut-être pas temps d'aller au bout de
cette traversée
c'est surtout aussi de pouvoir partager
ce que nous voyons ce que nous avons vu
en antarctique de ses paysages
magnifiques c'est cela qui pour nous a
beaucoup de sens et prendre des
photographies des vidéos en antarctique
lorsqu'il était moins 40 moins 50 degrés
c'est extrêmement compliqué la gestion
des panneaux solaires pour recharger les
batteries et compliqué le fait de
prendre dans cette raynaud une charge
supplémentaire d'une vingtaine de kilos
uniquement pour du matériel
photographique est extrêmement difficile
parfois même plus difficile que
d'effectuer tous ces kilomètres et on a
souvent eu tous les deux peur d'y
laisser quelques doigts mais nous
continuons à avancer coûte que coûte
avec cet objectif de partager ce que
nous avons vécu après 800 kilomètres
d'ascension nous atteignons le plateau
antarctique
le froid est de plus en plus extrêmes et
violent la température jusqu'à -50
peut-être moins on a arrêté de mesurer
lorsque la température a atteint moins
50 et à -50 on est vraiment dans la
survie on ne peut même plus arrêté
quelques secondes parce que le corps se
refroidit les les droits les doigts ne
retrouve plus du tout de sensibilité et
l'on a peur tout simplement et alors la
peur n'est pas temps pour soi que pour
l'autre dont on sait qu'ils s'ouvrent
auquel on est très attachés évidemment
dont on sait qu'ils souffrent même s'il
ne montre pas même si il continue de
sourire
on sait qu'ils souffrent en silence et
c'est probablement ce qui a été pour
stéphane y est pour moi le plus dur dans
cette aventure
on continue donc à avancer de cette
manière jusqu'à atteindre le pôle sud le
24 décembre
le soir de noël c'est magique c'est
magique parce que totalement imprévue
c'est magique parce qu'on se retrouve le
soir de noël au pôle sud
ensemble à vivre en quelque sorte notre
rêve c'est magique parce qu'on a déjà
accompli quelque chose qui est pour nous
très fort on a rendu à tous ceux qui
nous suivaient on a fait honneur à leur
confiance et pour nous ça a beaucoup de
sens ce moment là il est magique et en
même temps il est dramatique parce que
nous avons parcouru 916 km en 40 jours
il nous en reste 30 5 environ donc nous
décidons de nous alléger au maximum on
se décharge de quelques équipements
vidéo
photo tous les équipements de secours
sont mis de côté et on décide de
poursuivre avec un minimum d'équipement
en préservant naturellement nous rations
alimentaires et on repart le 25 décembre
le jour de noël pour essayer de finir
cette traversée à ce moment-là de la
traversée nous savons qu'il faudra
effectuer 35 km en ski tous les jours
pour arriver au bout du bout et
atteindre la côte 35 km en moyenne c'est
plus que la moyenne qui a été réalisé
lors de l'expédition 30 en arctique a
réalisé en 1989 à l'aide d'une trentaine
de chiens de traîneaux et avec stéphanie
nous ne sommes que deux bipèdes déjà
très fatigué d'avoir traîné notre charge
sur plus de 1000 km mais nous repartons
quelques jours plus tard mi janvier
il nous reste encore devant nous
l'immensité de l'antarctique 600 km à
parcourir et quinze jours désormais et
nous n'avons plus que deux options
abandonnées maintenant ou bien
poursuivre cette aventure et poursuivre
cette aventure s'est réalisé un marathon
par jour pendant quinze jours
impensable d'abandonner après tout ce
que nous avons réalisé alors que nous
commençons à toucher ce rêve du doigt
nous décidons de poursuivre cette
aventure le brouillard s'en mêle et
complexifie notre progression nous
skions 12 heures 13 heures 14 heures par
jour et nous dormons quatre ou cinq
heures par nuit pour pouvoir aller au
bout de cette aventure arrive le
soixante quatorzième jour de
l'expédition
le dernier jour de l'expédition celui au
bout du cal au terme duquel nous devons
atteindre cette extrémité pour pouvoir
reprendre cet avion et repartir vers
vers le chili puis vers la france
et ce jour là il nous reste 60
kilomètres à parcourir
c'est aussi la zone la plus crasse et de
l'expédition
mais après 20 heures d'efforts on arrive
enfin
exténué à 4 heures du matin sur le bord
du continent on a parcouru 2000 45 km en
74 jours on est arrivé au bout de notre
rêve
que restera-t-il de cette expédition
pour stéphanie et pour moi les
kilomètres n'ont pas beaucoup
d'importance
la performance non plus le fait que ce
soit l'expédition en ce qu'il a traversé
en ski de l'antarctique d'un point à
l'autre du continent la plus longue
jamais réalisée n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance
ce qui est important pour nous c'est
toutes les belles rencontres que l'on a
pu le faire autour de cette expédition
avant et après et avec vous ce soir
notamment
c'est cela qui restera à jamais nos
traces ont été déjà balayé par le vent
et par la neige mais le souvenir d'un
rêve qui s'est réalisé lui ne s'effacera
jamais et au delà de de ce rêve qui
s'est réalisé le plus important aussi
c'est pour moi pour stéphanie d'avoir
redonné par le simple fait de se lancer
dans cette aventure d'avoir redonné à
notre courbe de croissance
cette forme exceptionnelle qu'elle avait
lorsque nous étions enfants à tel point
qu'aujourd'hui je n'ai qu'une seule
envie une envie très forte c'est de
reprendre ces équipements avec lesquels
je suis arrivé de les remettre sur moi
et de repartir à l'aventuré
je veux continuer de grandir toujours et
vous